all right this is super serious and so
we're not going to make light of this uh
Lauren bobert the radical and repugnant
sanctimonious
Republican congresswoman who talks about
how Christianity is the one moral path
and Christianity needs to be involved in
civil government and all these different
how everybody else is a bad parent if
they have a a trans kid or if they're
gay or whatever okay that Lauren bobert
was potentially involved in covering up
her own then husband soon to be
ex-husbands alleged
child abuse
against one of her own kids
there is
the story of the facts and there is the
story of Lauren bobert's I know with
Rhonda sanctimonious it sounds crazy to
use the word but her sanctimonious
pleading about how she is the moral one
when she may have been involved in this
so let me tell you what the allegations
are in December Lauren bobert's teen son
called 9-1-1
and the reason that her son called 9-1-1
was to report that his dad Lauren
bobert's husband was abusing him that he
was quote throwing me in the house
the teens sobbed through the two-minute
call saying he didn't understand why his
dad was mad
the boy called back soon after
suddenly denying it happened with Lauren
bobert jumping on the call to say the
boy is fine
okay so two minute phone call
the teen calls and says my dad's
throwing me around I don't know why the
call ends Garfield County Sheriff's
Office deputies are going out to Lauren
bobert's house the teen calls back and
says oh I take it back and suddenly
Lauren bobert's on the phone and says my
son doesn't need any help
Jason bober denied to the deputies that
he got physical with his son put out
Lauren bobert put out a statement
yesterday saying the safety and
well-being of my family are the most
important things in the world we've had
tough times and heartache I've taken
action to ensure there are better days
ahead presumably meaning that she is
going to be divorcing her husband an
affidavit says that when Jason bobert
was served with the petition for divorce
he became extremely angry
he started yelling and using profanity
and he uh Lauren bobert denied that
that's what happened
when we go back to 2004 we know that
Jason bobert was arrested and pleaded
guilty to public indecency and lewd
exposure after allegedly exposing his
genitals to two young women one of whom
was 16 years old at a bowling alley
Lauren bobert defends her husband in her
book claiming that he was actually the
one who was harassed by a female
bartender who said show me your genitals
so we have a situation here where if it
is true
it appears as though Lauren bobert
potentially realizing
the very bad situation that it would be
for her
for police to show up at her house just
a few months ago
potentially to arrest her husband for
child abuse that her son called 9-1-1
and said was going on
the speculation is she made her son call
and retract that allegation
that his dad bobert's husband
was becoming physically violent and if
that is the case she would be involved
in a cover-up of child abuse now we
don't know that that is what took place
we are still learning more about this
but it's not about getting involved in
the personal lives of these individuals
beyond the fact that they want to they
both declare themselves the top and
mightiest Arbiters of morality and
ethics
and they go around telling everybody
else what they're doing wrong
based on sexual identity or gender or
whatever the case may be
and in addition to that that they stake
a claim for their religion which in this
you know with Marjorie Taylor green and
Lauren bober and others it's always
Christianity that Christianity is the
moral and ethical law of the land that
should be the law of civil government so
they are sanctimonious Hypocrites now
whatever the truth is about whatever
abuse
one of Lauren bobert's Sons may have
suffered it's a law enforcement matter
but to the extent that these folks want
to make law and tell everybody else
what's right and what's wrong they are
horrible sanctimonious Hypocrites one of
our sponsors today is fume not
everything in a bad habit is wrong so
instead of a drastic uncomfortable
change why not just remove the bad part
from your habit fume is an Innovative
award-winning device that does exactly
that fume is not electronic there's no
Vapor or harmful chemicals fume is just
a delicious flavored air that makes
replacing your bad habit easy your fume
comes with an adjustable airflow dial
and is designed with movable Parts which
is great for fidgeting which can be
great for people breaking bad habits
look at what people online are saying
they weren't sure what to expect but
ended up loving the taste and the feel
stopping is something lots of people put
off because it's difficult to do but
switching to fume is easy and enjoyable
there's no reason that you can't be the
next fume success story head on over to
trifum.com and use the code Pacman to
save 10 percent when you get the journey
pack which comes with the device and
three flavors the link is down below